and then the check this out and also
it's a movie called mr. 3000 mr. 3000
for Bernie Mac when he played the
baseball player I said we listen I said
this is a baseball film I can be in this
film I can play that character because I
used to be a batboy for Major League
Baseball with the batboy for the Detroit
Tigers so I got a chance to work about
all the great players like Ken Griffey
junior a rock many Ramirez stelsel
filter so I know what goes on in the
locker room I know how they act so I put
together a press crit this would be for
911 and I I called micro Iseman his
office he was the president at Disney at
the time I said Michael I talked to his
assistant and I saw used to be a bad boy
for the Anaheim Angels which I wasn't
which I was I was a bad boy fat and high
in Japan they played against the Detroit
Tigers and I was able to prove that
because I had pictures in a uniform with
tim salmon other players and I want to
audition for this movie about mr. 3000
the baseball player and I'd be right for
it so I they said bring down your
brought down my press kit took it to the
office Michael Eisner looked at it then
gave it to dick cook who I didn't know
who he was at the moment and he started
off at the amusement park at Disney and
became like president of Disney and they
got me the audition audition for Gail
Goldberg and guilt over and said how did
you get this odd to difference because
it came down from the top and that's how
I got the auditions I said I used to be
a bad word for Anna angels and i took my
press kit over to Michael Eisner in them
and I got the audition and I did a great
job and I thought I was gonna get that
movie and but I didn't get it because it
was a package deal Gil Kofman say hey
bear i'm sorry you did great but it was
a package deal the director the bernie
mac and other actor at all with the same
agency it's a family I said this is
ridiculous I gotta fight against this
time as we do my own thing and then once
you start doing your own thing then
people start coming after you to do
their projects how do you get through to
Michael eyes are on the phone Oh until I
thought I caught um o'clock Disney and I
spoke to his assistant and I said this
is a bearing little tonight I used to be
a bad boyfriend in high angels and I
want to audition for the movie mr. 3000
baseball movie and she said all right
just bring your press kit down
I brought my press kit down and gave it
to her and she gave it to Michael Eisner
we didn't gave him to dick cook Wow did
you ever speak to him on the father's be
too much ok so you dealt with the
assistant but that's great i mean so
many people try these things and they
get hung up on they get sorry we don't
take our soliciting material whatever it
is what are your tips on even getting a
little bit of a conversation i think
because you gotta you gotta have some
type of emotional connection at that
time disney on the anaheim angels and by
me being a bad boy for them it's like
I'm part of their family even though I
didn't work for Disney I work for the
Detroit Tigers but I bat boy for Disney
about backwards and in high angels so
it's like that emotional connection ok i
was able to connect mm-hmm and i was
able to show pictures of me in a uniform
so that's what helped me is there a fine
line between being persistent and being
overbearing uh yes I think overbearing
is when they say no you still call them
ok continue to call until they tell you
know because sometimes people that are
very successful and productive are very
busy and so until they tell you know and
that's when you stop ok and and so for
those that don't want to quote take no
for an answer what's your
what's your advice to them for people
who don't want to take no for an answer
can you explain it to me like yeah some
people did just say you know what I
always get my way and I'm gonna get this
and you will not tell me no and they
don't mean it in a malicious way but
they just mean it in a way where I get
what I want and I make things happen to
those people would you say if someone
tells you no find another person that
would say yes kind of thing I mean would
you if the one tells you no go to the
next person it didn't go back to that
person that told you note at a later
time and then show them something you
have done but that's up to something you
have done whatever you asked me for you
go back to them show them this is what i
have done this without asking for i did
it anyway i would like to be a part of
my team now all right or assist me in my
project now that sounds good yeah yeah
so so it doesn't mean a final no but
come back with a new thing right is that
okay like that yes because I have a lady
right now he's very successful who wants
to invest in me and help me and
sometimes I sent her an email I don't
hear anything that means no then I send
her something yes and she starts talking
to me so you have to understand how
people communicate and and so it's
almost kind of like psychology yeah that
is that people communicate different
ways some people don't say no they just
don't say anything so you oh I said that
means no again
you